speaking of the libs misunderstanding
things and also having a blatant
disregard for human life
there's a story I bet you saw this go
around the news or at least social media
over the weekend a Nebraska teenager
a poor young girl was jailed for having
an abortion you said it couldn't happen
here we're living in the handmaid's tale
this girl went to jail for an abortion
allegedly according to David Frum David
from who's not just some crazy lib David
Frum was a speechwriter for George W
bush David Frum for a long time was
considered a leading conservative
intellectual he's now probably
considered a little bit more liberal but
many people would still call him on the
center right David Frum tweets out they
swore up and down they wouldn't send
girls and women to prisons for abortions
they lied
Brian Cohen who is a liberal he's been
on I think he's been on this show before
I've been on TV with him before at least
Brian Cohen tweeted out uh quote a
Nebraska teenager has been sentenced to
jail and charged as a felon after ending
her pregnancy with abortion pills she
faces up to five years in prison this
teen
was not sent oh no I'm sorry this is
what the the community note says I love
Community notes Community notes it's
probably the best feature that Elon has
brought back and really built up during
his tenure at Twitter the community
notes Here on Brian Cohen's post says
the teen was not sentenced for having a
chemically induced abortion during her
third trimester but for burning burying
and concealing a dead body
so she wasn't charged even though she
had a a an abortion she murdered her
child in the third trimester if you've
never seen a an ultrasound of what a
baby looks like in the third trimester
do it just looks like any Ordinary Baby
in this teenage girl murdered her baby
who looks just like any other baby that
you'd see in newborn
that's not what she was sentenced for
she was sentenced to 90 days in prison
not all that long
not for murdering her precious little
child which she did but for disposing of
this Baby's dead body in a way that
desecrated the body and tried to set on
fire and all sorts of crazy stuff not
only is the girl going to prison for 90
days
the girl's mother faces potentially up
to five years in prison because the
mother 42 years old helped the girl do
it helped the girl bury the body just
like any Street criminal I mean really
bad street criminal any mafioso any
mobster who says here come on over here
will help you bury the bodies out here
in Las Vegas yeah you go through the
deserted bodies buried everywhere that
kind of stuff this is what the mother
has done
abortion in Nebraska is not totally
banned should be but isn't you can kill
your baby in Nebraska up to 12 weeks
up to a third of the pregnancy
this girl did it at 28 weeks this baby
could have lived outside the womb she
could have just induced labor
given birth to this baby put the baby up
for adoption she never would have had to
think about it again she wouldn't have
been inconvenienced for one single
solitary second she chose instead to
murder her child and she wasn't even put
in jail for that
she was put in jail for what
this is the Crux of it all
the reason that the libs have to lie
about this story the reason this law is
actually very instructive
maybe in some places you'll hear people
calling for punishments of people for
having abortions that's not the
mainstream pro-life position it's
punished the abortionist it's punished
people for burning and desecrating a
body say but but not for
even having an illegal abortion not not
for the mother to do that but but this
law is very instructive in that
it reminds you
there is a body
whose body is it it's the baby's body
why do the lips have to lie about this
story because if you read about what
happened here you recognize that the
baby is a baby if the baby were just a
clump of cells
you wouldn't have to bury it
or you wouldn't have to try to destroy
the body to hide it from people all of
whom can recognize just looking with
their own two eyes this is a little baby
sometimes people say about Richard Nixon
he didn't he didn't commit the crime of
the Watergate break-in
what he was guilty of is the cover-up
well that's what we're seeing here the
crime is the cover-up because the
cover-up is a particularly ghastly thing
where you're where you're hacking up a
body like and like the most Stone Cold
psycho you can imagine Jeffrey Dahmer
kind of stuff
and they know that when people hear that
story they're going to to not only side
with the justice system here at the very
least it's probably lenient but they're
going to turn on abortion they're going
to turn toward the cause of life and so
these Libs have to lie about it when
things get really dumb and stupid in the
world
sometimes the economy can falter and
when economy starts falter you don't
want to check out Birch gold right now
text Knowles to 98 98 98 we are days
away from the Durbin Accords the
greatest threat to the US Dollars Global
dominance in the past 80 years on August
22nd brics Nations Brazil Russia India
China South Africa are expected to
announce the launch of a new
international super currency fully
backed by gold or other Commodities this
is part of their long-term plan to
supplant the U.S and the dollar as
cornerstones of the Global Financial
system you can protect your IRA or 401K
from The Fallout from this Landmark
Announcement by diversifying with gold
from Birch gold historically gold has
been a safe haven in times of high
uncertainty which is
right now when currencies fail gold is a
safe haven how much more time does the
Dollar have protect your savings with
gold Birch gold as an A plus rating with
the Better Business Bureau thousands of
happy customers text Knowles Canada WLS
298 98.98 get your free info kit on gold
if a central bank digital currency
becomes a reality it will be nice to
have some gold to depend upon text
Knowles Canon wlas to 98.98 98. right
now go to carson.com Knowles buying a
new car can be a stressful experience
for anyone especially if you're a first
time buyer or have no credit before you
walk into a dealership and spend the
whole day with crowds and stress and the
potential not even to find the right car
you've got to check out carsing carsing
is completely changing the way you buy a
car online by partnering with Credit
Agencies and lenders and over 25
000 dealers Nationwide karzing provides
you with everything you need before
stepping foot onto a dealership once you
find the right car at your ideal budget
all you've got to do is bring your saved
deal voucher with you to the dealership
to finalize your next ride it is super
simple even if you are not in the market
for a new car you should check out
Carson anyway Carson's online shopping
experience goes beyond mirror images you
can dive deep into each vehicle's specs
features performance capabilities zoom
in on the craftsmanship of the Interior
Marvel at Cutting Edge technology admire
what sets these cars away from the rest
car reversing helps make your experience
faster cheaper and less stressful
carzing.com Knowles head on over there
today find the best deals near you
carson.com
Knowles it's my favorite CNN Headline
ever
it's my favorite one it's my favorite
story it's not just CNN here
it's a it's a liberal proposal more
broadly here's the headline
giant kites could pull cargo ships
across the ocean
and slash their carbon emissions
now it if you're watching right now you
can see the picture of this but if
you're not just maybe close your eyes
picture what this would look like giant
kites
pulling ships
you may have seen kite Surfers in action
harnessing the power of the wind to pull
them over the sea now imagine try to
imagine this the same concept applied to
a 1 000 square meter kite flying 300
meters above the water only instead of
towing a surfer across the waves it's
helping to propel
a colossal cargo ship across the ocean
well that's the basic idea behind the
c-wing a technology being developed is
being developed now this is obviously in
the very early stages being developed by
French company air Seas which it says
could help cargo ships reduce their fuel
consumption and cut their carbon
emissions by an average of 20 percent
the Liberals have just discovered the
concept
of sailboats
sailboats
were invented in 4000 BC
at least sailboats have been around
for at least
six thousand years in the libs
just exasperated in their excitement
they say we've got it we've got the
answer to environmentalism instead of
having a ship powered by I don't know
oil or cold or something like that what
we're going to do we're gonna we're
gonna fix this big thing to it what do
we call it's like a kite but is there
another word could we call it yeah like
a sale and the sale is going to propel
the boat and what we could call it
we could call it a sailboat
the libs love
Reinventing normal things
and making them Dumber this is something
I've observed about the lips from for
many years this is just the most recent
example of it
and the libs in the 60s they did they
decided
they were going to have these new forms
of living man they were going to live
like it's like a commune man and but
they're all going to work together you
know on the commune and so like one
person man they're gonna bake the bread
you know and the other man they're gonna
like teach the kids you know and someone
else on this new age of Aquarius kind of
commune living man they're gonna Farm
the food man and Oh you mean like a town
they're gonna you're gonna live in a
town no man it's way cooler and
[Applause]
now their new one relatively new and
they'll say what we need we need
mindfulness
do you we're just so wrapped up in our
days we need what we need to do is stop
all of our business and all of our
distractions we're gonna sit we're gonna
kind of close our eyes and we're just
gonna we're just gonna be mindful and
we're gonna say things in our heads
like prayer you're gonna pray well no
man prayers stodgy and old and
conservative we're gonna we're just
gonna say things in our heads that
articulate our desires and our our
gratitude and our adoration
it's different in that mindfulness it's
just when you pray to yourself you just
worship yourself instead of prayer is
when you pray to God but okay yeah it's
called it's called prayer it's been
around for a while
even gender ideology by the way
don't worry I think we can keep this one
on YouTube I think this one's allowed to
stay on YouTube I'm not I'm just I'm
actually saying a nice thing about
gender ideology the best part of gender
ideology is finally for the first time
in a very long time the Liberals
admitted that the soul exists
that's the best part that's the silver
lining in the storm cloud of gender
ideology is that the Liberals finally
admitted for the first time in a long
time that we're not just bags of meat
that we're not just our biology that
there's something else to us
now we
traditionally called us the soul
that's what pretty much everyone for all
of human history everywhere has called
it but now we call it the Gen this is my
gender identity or my true self or
whatever they want to call it but they
just take
basic normal things about life and they
make them Dumber like our new like the
new kite affixed cargo ship
formerly known as a sailboat boy what a
great clip that was make sure that you
ring the bell subscribe to the Michael
Knowles show channel we'll see you next
time